hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel and this week
i am going to be answering
your property investment questions where
you can literally ask me
anything about what i'm doing what deals
are going on
or about how i can help you with your
property investment deals
so please do me a massive favor comment
your questions below and i'm going to do
my very best to answer those questions
also if you enjoy my channel hit the
like button
and don't forget to subscribe and turn
on the notification
bell so you don't miss a video so let's
have a look at your questions from last
week
we've got creating your prosperity who
says
for four bad unlicensed hmos
what legal requirements do i need to
comply with
to make this happen and also is it a
legal requirement to have communal areas
in licensed and unlicensed hmos
the answer to your question is very
simple if
you have rooms where they are less
than 100 square feet the bedrooms
you need a communal area if the bedrooms
are
100 square feet or more you do not need
a communal bedroom
in terms of licensed and unlicensed hmos
if it's
licensed you need to follow the
guidelines of the
of that particular council to make sure
that it is compliant
namely things like fire doors smoke
alarms
escape windows and there'll be a list of
things that you need to have your
property up to a certain standard if
it's licensed
if the property is less than five people
living there
it will unlikely need to be licensed
so you don't need to have a compliant
hmo
per se however the way that i advise and
teach and train people
is if it's licensed or if it's not
licensed
have it to the standard whereby it would
get a license if needed
because you don't know if they're going
to change the rules and on top of that
you want it to be a very safe good
hmo property so regardless of whether
you need a license or not
have the standard as though you were
going to have a license
hope that helps
says hi samuel what are the reasons for
deals
not going through in property deal
sourcing
the reason i pronounced the name strange
is because it's abd space ul
all right abdul the reasons that a deal
might fall through
could be that the seller just changes
their mind
it could be that the mortgage is not
offered on the property the lender won't
lend on the property because there's a
problem with the house
it could be that there's not a problem
with the house
but the lender down values the house
meaning that the buyer needs to put a
higher deposit amount in
and they don't want to do that it could
be that the
buyer changes their mind and finds
another property
there's a whole host of reasons why
property deals might not go through
there could be legal problems it could
be there could be
um a flying
freehold or a ransom strip that's found
which is preventing access there's a lot
of reasons
a mine shaft could be close by which
gets picked up on searches
when the solicitor's going through the
searches now
if you're packaging it to sell it to
somebody
and the house falls through and it's not
the investor's fault
so you've taken money off the investor
let's say you packaged the deal you sold
it you made 3 000 pounds
boom i would say never spend that money
until the deal has completed and they
have the keys
in their hands in the meantime keep that
money sat in a client
account and make sure that the deal does
go through to fruition
hope that helps okay andy p
how is your castle going and your leads
land
don't forget to document for us don't
worry about that i'm documenting
everything so
the castle is going very well it's very
sl
look it's a big project the castle is
we're currently in the process of before
we do any more works we're currently in
the process of trying to get more
planning permission to do some extra
works and that is taking a very long
time because it can do
getting planning permission can take
months sometimes even
years especially when you're talking
about a historic building
like ribsford house however uh i am
documenting everything
and there's some things that i can't
necessarily put out right now on the
castle because of
sensitivity reasons there's also um
filming going on in the castle there's
some
netflix movie producers that are using
ribs for house
to do some filming which is good for me
because it means i'm getting paid
when it's not habitable so it kind of
works but
everything is being documented i can
assure you and there will be
some updates but it's a slow long
process in terms of
the leeds land i'm not quite sure which
leeds land you're referring to because
i've got a couple of
bits going on developments going on in
leeds um
we did complete on some land in leeds
which i think i might have posted about
on social media on instagram
there is going to be a video coming very
very soon
with a full update on that and our plans
to build and what it is that we're doing
but that's all completed and um again
i'm documenting everything it's
sometimes i have to be careful on the
timing
because i've got planning consultants
i've got uh ben my business partner
and everybody and sometimes it's not
doesn't make sense to put things out on
youtube especially if we're dealing with
sites that we haven't quite bought yet
or if we haven't got planning permission
yet so i sometimes just need to be a
little bit careful
but i am documenting everything and
everything will always come out
at its right course on those particular
deals in question
so hope that helps and thank you for
your question
marcos jally do
you think the financial freedom
challenge would be possible in spain or
better in the uk
marcos i reckon it would work pretty
much anywhere unless you're working in a
country where it's illegal to
make money in property if you're in a
communist country
maybe it would be difficult but i don't
really think many countries
are communist actually but technically
there isn't a communist country in the
in the world right now um technically
um so would it work in spain sure
i've got students in spain that are
killing it i've actually got a friend
who is making such good money in spain
in property i'm tempted to go out myself
and join in
in italy in all i think the strategies
that i
teach work pretty much worldwide you
just need to sometimes apply them
to your country the rules might be
slightly different but yeah i think the
financial freedom challenge would blow
in spain so you should go do it don't
wait for me to come and move into your
house
just go do it okay heidi baker
um question do i really need a solicitor
for the services i'm providing with rent
to rent deal packaging
rent to rent deals and property bills
and if i do use a solicitor's job
contracts can i reuse those contracts
so hate it yes you can reuse those
contracts if you get a solicitor to draw
up
a deal your terms and conditions with
deal packaging
and all the different contracts your
non-disclosure agreements
heads of terms if you get everything
drawn up by a solicitor you
can reuse that contract again and again
and again which is great news
same with rent to rent you can reuse the
contract you just need to tweak it a
little bit
if you're putting a lot of money into a
deal or for example if you've got a
lease option agreement
where you've got a stake in that
property you want to get a solicitor to
come on board and represent the seller
you don't want to use a template
agreement because
if the the the the other party in the
deal
tried to break the contract and it went
to court
you got so much to lose in a lease
option agreement
you want a solicitor to represent the
seller
however with general standard deals
like rent to the rents and packaging
deals you just tweak the contract it
wouldn't be viable
to get a solicitor to write up a new
contract
which would cost about 1200 pounds by
the way
every time you packaged and sold a deal
you'd wipe out half your profit
you can't do that so i hope that helps
harry says i have a question regarding
interest-only mortgages i'm currently
developing my portfolio and i'm very
familiar with the concept of good debt
but at some point when you're a certain
age does it become hard to keep
extending interest-only mortgages does
the debt need to be prepaid eventually
no it no it doesn't uh my plan is to die
with a lot of debt
if you've if you've got listen you i
don't think you do understand the
difference fully
between good debt and bad debt because
good debt is facilitating your business
if you've got money like a buy to let
mortgage
and that mortgage is being paid it's not
being paid by you
it's been paid by your tenants it's the
business
the tenants are paying the mortgage
you want to die with debt
this is this is just my opinion by the
way when i die
people say but then you're going to
leave debt to your children no i'm not
no i'm not because i got my portfolio
which is worth
millions and millions of pounds and then
i've got my debts
which are also worth millions of pounds
but if you add up my whole portfolio and
you take away all my debt
you're left with a lot of profit
millions of pounds of profit by the way
so i'm not going to leave debt to my
kids i'm going to leave
net worth high net worth individuals are
also high debt worth
individuals so yeah good debt is there
just to facilitate your business and you
want it there
forever in my opinion
kieran says my parents own their
personal house
mortgage paid etc worth around 230 000
pounds
is there a way their son as their son i
can release the equity to begin
investing in my journey
you can't release equity from someone
else's house
now what you could do is they could
release equity
and then they could either gift or loan
you
the money sure yeah
but you can't obviously refinance the
house it's not your house but they could
refinance
put that give that money to you you
could use it to build your portfolio
and have an agreement with them that you
either pay them back with interest or
you don't you pay them back with no
interest whatever you want to work out
of course you can do that fran what are
the differences between getting a buy to
let mortgage
doing the brr method and using a
bridging loan to do the same thing
i understand the advantages of a
bridging loan but i feel like the risk
is higher
noting the higher the risk the higher
the reward for a first-time bar investor
who is more worried about the high
interest on a bridging loan what would
you suggest
fran you've got it all mixed up
if you get a bridging loan you're not
paying high interest
you're not paying if the deal is right
the the interest is a business
cost
people are afraid of failure of
debt and of
outgoing expenses you need to
lean in to failure debt
and expenses if done in the right way
let me give you an example fran
if you buy a house for 100 grand and you
need to spend 50 grand on it
that's 150 grand all in if the new value
is 250 grand
that means that you made a hundred grand
profit
right however you're only going to make
100 grand profit if you
put your own money into the deal because
if you put your own money into the deal
100 grand 50 grand your money
and then you make 100 grand 100 profit
there's no expenses now of course
there's tax and there will be legal fees
but but but take my point
now getting a bridging loan is just
saying oh
i'll need to pay my bridging loan
company
10 grand but they'll put the money in
or most of it so what that means is
you're going to pay them out of the
profit so to say oh but it's expensive
it's like
what so expensive if you're paying
someone out of the profit
it's cheaper than a joint venture
partner i take on joint venture partners
i'll give them 50
of the profit sometimes is that
expensive it's not expensive
it's not costing me anything because i'm
paying them out of
the profit you know interest
on a loan is not your expense
you're just paying the interest out of
the profit
and you need to get this this is
business
this is basic business matt walker my
question
if possible is how would you best advise
someone starting out who's interested in
biorefurbish refinance rent
brr borough would you advise getting a
bridging loan for the whole cost
if not what would you do thank you all
right
most bridging companies namely all
aren't going to give you the entire
amount they're not going to say to you
go back to my previous example 100 grand
purchase price
50 grand renovation costs 150 grand in
total they're not going to go oh
i'll pay for the i'll give you 150 grand
they're not going to do that they must
buy the house themselves
but you found it though yeah but they
want they still want to see
skin in the game and they want security
here's how it works right
bridging company they're going to give
you the money now if you
don't pay them the money back and you
will pay the money back why
how because you'll pay them out of the
profits
but let's say you messed up let's say
you found a really bad deal
you've had a really bad deal oh that
coffee's nice what's that
new coffee machine let's say that you
messed up
let's say you found a really bad deal
okay and you thought that it was going
to be worth 250
you need a hundred and then 50 grand on
the renovation and you think it's going
to be worth 250
but actually you've messed up and it's
not
and and you've bought it for 100 and you
spent 50
but actually now it's only worth 150
okay messed up let's say a bridging
company puts in all the money
and then you go oh man i'm sorry
bridging company
i bought it for 100 i spent 50 on it but
it's only worth 150.
i can't pay you back and they go
what you need to pay me and you just for
whatever reason refuse to pay them back
okay
and the bridging company what they'll
then do they'll have a first
charge on the property so they will then
repossess the house they'll
take it off you and then when they take
it off
you they'll sell it as a repossession
sale when you go and you see those
houses where they've got do not use over
the toilets and stuff that's because the
banks have just grabbed it they don't
know anything about the house
they don't care about the house they
want their money back
right so they're going to grab the house
off you they're going to sell it
now when those take off and sell it they
want their money back they want it quick
number one they're going to have lost
all the interest they would have got
number two is when they sell it quick
they're probably gonna sell it below
market value
so they might end up selling for 125
grand so they've got 125 grand back
and they've received no interest and
they gave you money
they've lost money
they don't want to lose money so what do
they do instead instead
they say to you oh you're putting in a
hunt you need to point 100 and then 50.
well we're not going to give you the
whole amount we'll give you 60
and then you need to put the other money
in why do they do that
because then if you don't pay them back
they take the house off yeah they sell
it and do what they need to do and this
and they've made profit they're still
that's still good so from their point of
view you might go that's not fair well
of course it's fair
they need security if you do your job
right
you buy for a hundred you spend 50 on it
you use 65 percent of their money
i mean sometimes they'll lend you 65 of
the purchase price and then 100 of the
development so
they'll put in a lot of it but you need
to put in a bit
how are you going to put in a bit when
you maybe got no money you're going to
borrow it from another
investor they don't care where it comes
from as long as it's there and as long
as they've got a charge
they don't care they don't care if it's
a bank loan
they don't care if it was from your man
they don't care where it's from
but you need to show some skill in the
game so you get the bridging loan
and you get your mama's money or
whatever
and then you buy the house now if you
mess up
you could lose it and get repossessed
terrible
if you do it right and you play your
cards right you borrow the monies
you buy it for a hundred you then borrow
more money off the bridging company
development finance
on the 50 grand refurb but then the
house is worth
250 in this example you made a hundred
grand profit
you give your mom back five grand
okay her money back plus five grand say
thanks give the bridging company
their money back plus 10 grand thanks
but you're left with 85 000 pounds
minus fees maybe 75 but you've not put
in any money of yourself
people say oh well how can you make
money with no money because you need to
know what you're doing
even though you're not putting any money
in you're still putting you'll still
have skin in the game
and you still haven't you have to find
the deal make it stack
that's how it works i hope this is
making sense and i hope this is helpful
if it is hit the like button let me know
troy gallacher i've just set up a
company and started doing viewings for
rent to rent what steps would you take
first
before putting in an offer as i
understand you need insurances and
contracts drawn up by solicitors
should i speak to a solicitor and sort
out sort it out first or worry about
that once the landlord has accepted an
offer
troy um i'd probably get your contract
sorry
because you want to have your contract
sorted so that when you're pitching
um landlords if you say are you ready to
sign on the dotted line and they say
yeah let's do it
you ready to move i wouldn't spend a
load of money um and rather than going
to solicitors and getting the contracts
listen you can you can listen i'm just
going to say this because i think it's
best for you
i'm not trying to be salesy or anything
i have a training program called the
rent to rent accelerator
it's a four week training program it
will teach you everything about rent to
rent and getting rental rents
included in the rent to rent accelerator
you also have all the contracts that you
need
to rent to an accelerator with all the
contracts you can get it right now
by the way this is at time i'm speaking
this might not be the case
in like a month or two months time but
right now you can get all that training
and all those contracts
for 495 pounds
so it's like it's less than half the
price of getting a solicitor to drop the
contract
and you've got all the training that
comes with it too it's a freaking no
brainer so i'll leave a link in the
description i would just go and get that
um i really would all right yang ray he
says
absolutely agree with you i'm glad you
agree angry
you've been inspirational i'll be
following you for the last three years
and everything you say is correct all
right fair enough
i've bought five houses now and still
buying
please stay with us and keep motivating
us with more videos love you man
okay it wasn't a question but yang i
appreciate that you know i really really
appreciate that and that that's the
reason why i do what i do
you know so any questions at all you
have
listen you can go and do further
training i'd love you to i'd love to see
you on the rent to rent accelerator four
week training program of all the
contracts
um get booked on it i'll leave a link in
the description i do a lot of free
training
and a lot of free webinars um i do these
youtube videos every single day i do a
youtube video why because i've made a
lot of money in property and now i feel
like it's my duty and my obligation
to openly share with other people so
sure some of the training
is um there's an investment for it a lot
of it is free
i hope you benefit comment your
questions below
and i look forward to seeing you guys
next time
[Music]